at one point during first season a game
of Thrones I was hoping to be a severed
head you know there was a scene where
Ned was killed and his head was on the
wall and Sansa was made to look at all
the heads on the wall it's quite a
moment I'll tell you that and I
suggested to David Benioff and Dan Weiss
that the three of us be the heads next
to next to Ned and and they were all
cool for the idea so we were all gonna
have our severed heads made and mounted
on the wall but then you know we were
like many television shows facing
budgetary problems and they found out
what those severed heads cost so they
said uh sorry George we can't we can't
afford to make up these special severed
heads for justice shot instead you know
they've recycle a lot of things in
Hollywood instead they they bought a big
box of used severed heads from a
previous a previous production and we we
put all the severed heads next to the
wall and they were cheap we got the box
I don't know what they came from the
severed heads that we got in the box but
they were cheap and they saved us money
and everything worked well except one of
the severed heads woods george w bush
and and that was fine too because he was
bald and nobody mentioned him until like
a year later when they're doing the the
the blu-ray version and one of the
directors doing the commentary said oh
and you see the head next to Ned that's
George W Bush and of course the the
right-wing talk radio got ahold of it
and it went crazy rush limbaugh was was
having kittens and people were claiming
we wanted to assassinate the
ex-president and you know it was we were
Hollywood liberals who had mounted head
and I'm trying to say oh no it was just
we just bought a big box of heads it
could have been anybody's heads in there